[Music]
as it turns out we didn't really say bye
bye to the cast of american pie here's
what they've all been up to since
appearing in the 1999 classic
jason biggs was the actor tasked with
bringing that infamous apple pie moment
to life and we can only imagine he had a
million questions for his director
before doing the deed that's probably
true of most of his scenes in american
pie because more than any other
character jim suffers the brunt of the
film's angsty teen indignities again not
again
not again man
is that possible whatever the case one
has to admire big's dedication to
enduring those indignities and he leans
so fully into every salacious moment
that you simply can't imagine american
pie without him while american pie
indeed made the relatively unknown biggs
a star he's had trouble replicating such
meteoric success in the years since
still the actor has made a mark in the
entertainment biz carving out a career
with films including loser saving
silverman and who we are now as well as
memorable work on netflix's prison
dramedy orange is the new black more
recently big starred on two short-lived
series the fox family sitcom outmatched
and the 2021 e-game show jason biggs
cash at your door
while american pie is essentially about
a bunch of horny dudes trying to score
it was also one of the first horny dudes
movies that fully acknowledge that horny
girls exist too and even if it clearly
objectifies some of its female
characters american pie really did
better than most teen sex flicks in
depicting its female characters as
fiercely intellectual human beings with
desires of their own i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna have sex now and it's gonna be
right and it's gonna be just perfect
perfect sex
please
allison hannigan's flute playing band
geek michelle is one of the film's
female characters most distinctly in the
middle of that equation mostly because
american pie doesn't initially paint her
as an object of desire that quickly
changes when she drops that shocking
line about the intimate nature of her
relationship with her flute at that
wholly unexpected turn she actually
becomes the adorable band-loving sex pot
that cinema didn't know it needed what's
my name say my name michelle michelle of
course out of all the young stars in the
original american pie hannigan was
likely the one who needed little
introduction to the film's target
audience because she'd already made a
splash on the small screen via buffy the
vampire slayer as willow rosenberg of
the film's cast hannigan is also the one
who scored the biggest post pie hit
joining another all-star comedy ensemble
for the primetime juggernaut known as
how i met your mother
of all the young men who got their big
break in american pie chris klein was
the one most primed for super stardom
that's largely because he's got chiseled
leading man looks but it helps that he's
a better than average actor has solid
comedic timing and can even belt out a
tune with the best of them
yeah magic
and as it happens 1999 was the year
klein seemed most destined for fame with
winning turns in both american pie as oz
the hunky but sensitive jock and in
critical fave election as paul the
lovably dimwitted football player
however american pie was clearly the
more high profile project and klein rode
the initial wave of stardom to a leading
role in the sci-fi action remake
rollerball as well as largely under-seen
supporting turns in we were soldiers and
just friends soon after that just
friend's appearance chris klein further
lost his way in hollywood spending much
of the mid 2000s appearing in
forgettable films and series too
numerous to recount klein finally
started to turn things around with a
supporting turn performance opposite
elijah wood in the gonzo fx dramedy
wilfred since then he's gone on to
deliver work in the cw hit the flash and
on netflix's warm and fuzzy hit sweet
magnolias as dr bill townsend
mina suvari had a fantastic 1999 and not
just because she played michelle in
american pie she also played angela in
future best picture winner american
beauty which was ironically released
just after suvari's other 1999 offering
american virgin since renamed live
virgin clearly 1999 was an all-american
year for mina suvari at the cinemas and
as it happens she played a virginal teen
in all three of those films though most
would agree her michelle in american pie
was the most honorable it was also the
role that put the actors piercing
vulnerability front and center and
allowed her to craft as ernest a
portrait of teenaged tenderness as the
screen has seen
in fact suvari has spent much of her
career trying to shed that innocent
persona a task made more difficult given
her own fragile features she's often
succeeded in that endeavor though with
edgier turns in films like sugar and
spice edmund and factory girl while
tsubari has some movies on the horizon
she's appeared frequently on the small
screen over the years playing in six
feet under chicago fire american woman
and american horror story since her
american pie breakout
if allison hannigan was the female cast
member of american pie who needed little
introduction to fans it's safe to say
thomasia nicholas was her male
counterpart of all the up-and-coming
talent in american pie he was the only
one who could count himself a full-on
child star having already spent a decade
in front of the camera before appearing
as kevin in the film that's great man
that's awesome nicholas's career pre-pie
is fairly impressive with the actor
earning credits on who's the boss
baywatch and married with children
before he was even 10 years old he'd
also scooped a big screen credit in
radio flyer before fronting rookie of
the year and disney's a kid in king
arthur's court as it was american pie
was really the first adult role in
thomasia nicholas's career and the actor
made the most of the moment crafting one
of the more amiable horny screen teams
in recent cinema once he got a taste of
more adult fare nicholas never looked
back to his family friendly beginnings
he scored complex roles in the likes of
the rules of attraction stealing sinatra
and indies like please give most
recently he portrayed walt disney in
walt before mickey and legendary
director martin scorsese in james
franco's star-studded indie zeroville
tara reid's pre-pie resume wasn't super
impressive but she'd still scored
scene-stealing turns in urban legend
cruel intentions and something like two
scenes in the coen brothers immortal
classic the big lebowski
bran can't watch though or
that's marvelous still her work as vicky
displayed a depth many hadn't seen from
reed before one which both male and
female fans of american pie could easily
relate to reed seemed destined for
stardom after the film's release and
reinforced her name with roles in
underperforming flicks like dr t and the
women josie and the pussycats and
national lampoon's van wilder and don't
forget her funny arc on scrubs
we still die
we still what if the elevator cable
snapped even if we timed it out
perfectly and jumped up right before
impact we'd still be crushed to death i
wish i'd taken the stairs however like
many of her american pie co-stars reed
had some trouble in the mid-2000s
nevertheless she's become a regular
fixture of b-movies and schmaltzy
christmas flicks and made an appearance
as herself in amazon's hyper-violent
superhero satire the boys
natasha leon stole the show as the
gloriously clippy intellectual jessica
projecting attitude wit and genuine
warmth well beyond her ears
comprende you mean an orgasm you got it
stud of course those who'd been tracking
the actor's career prior to american pie
were already familiar with her sardonic
charm thanks largely to her breakout
turn the year prior in the classic indie
comedy slums of beverly hills however
things have been a bit complicated in
the years since american pie for leon
with the actors personal and
professional life seeing plenty of ups
and downs but even in spite of the
struggles leon is perhaps the pie star
with the highest batting average when
the camera's rolling stealing scenes in
indie flicks such as but i'm a
cheerleader dai mommy dai and at astra
she's also appeared in television series
like new girl weeds and all manner of
projects in between lyon is probably
best known for her heartbreaking work on
netflix's prison dramedy orange is the
new black a role that truly breathed new
life into her career it came courtesy of
a daring and skillful performance in the
serial comic series russian doll
did somebody say actors who've seen
their share of ups and downs since their
american pie breakthrough because sean
william scott has certainly seen his
scott made his big screen debut in the
film turning what might have been little
more than a supporting turn as the token
teen movie jerk into a career defining
triumph of cinematic smarm
no way
steve you could at least look at me when
you say that in scott's hands stiffler
was a teen movie jerk for the ages with
the actor indulging in enough stilted
attitude boorish entitlement and vulgar
language to make a mean girl blush so
good was scott in the role and in
ensuing sequels that it's safe to assume
he'll never fully break free from
stiffler's surprisingly long shadow can
i get a hallelujah
that hasn't stopped him from trying
however the actor spent much of the
2000s on the verge of super stardom
appearing in numerous classic comedies
such as old school dude wears my car and
road trip but every time he seemed to
take a step forward there was another
bulletproof monk or mr woodcock to knock
him back to personal demons eventually
caught up with scott however and save
for 2011's misfit hockey marvel goon the
2010s were a rough stretch he's been on
the rebound though with a return to the
animated wilds of the ice age franchise
a goon sequel and a starring role as a
small town minister on the fox comedy
welcome to flash
while american pie broke a little ground
in the teen sex comedy genre by giving
the ladies their due it's still very
much a film focused on the male
characters that means there's a lot of
objectification going on and shannon
elizabeth's foreign exchange student
nadia is ground zero for most of it so
much so that she doesn't have much
dialogue in the film and what she does
have leans heavily into the realm of
male fantasy
i could change cloths at your place
you have as it is if american pie were
made today it's possible nadia wouldn't
even be in it but she is and if we're
being completely honest shannon
elizabeth does her best to make her more
of an actual human being than the script
ever bothers to unfortunately not many
filmmakers have seen past her looks over
the years which means there aren't many
standout roles on her post pie resume
she was however in kevin smith's jay and
silent bob strike back and its recent
sequel she also scored a recurring role
on that 70s show and she scored some
laughs and scary movie plus she got to
give nadia some much needed refining in
the 2012 misfire american reunion
eddie k thomas showed legit comic chops
as paul finch aka the wisdom-seeking
know-it-all in american pie thomas has
more than kept himself busy in the years
since finch infamously did the pool
table mambo with stiffler's mom in the
waning moments of the first film women
like a fine wine only get better with
age like virtually all his co-stars
thomas returned for three american
pisces he also landed a steady gig
providing the high-pitched voice of
comically troubled team barry as well as
various minor characters in nearly 100
episodes of the long-running animated
comedy american dad he featured
prominently in the harold and kumar
franchise as well but aside from those
projects there are a few near misses
spotting his resume such as till death
and tom green's freddy got fingered most
famously kay spent four years portraying
dr toby quinn curtis a super genius
crime solver on the cbs crime procedural
scorpion
older viewers who saw american pie when
it hit theaters in 1999 were likely
already familiar with eugene levy who
portrayed jim's progressive and
understanding to a fault dad
well we'll just tell your mother that
that we ate it all an influential major
comedy star in the 1970s and early 1980s
levy was an original prominent cast
member on various sctv late night sketch
shows produced in his native canada this
earned him supporting roles in several
major 80s comedy movies including
national lampoon's vacation splash club
paradise and armed and dangerous after
acting steadily in numerous little
heralded and little watched projects
american pie proved to be a major
comeback vehicle for levy he would go on
to appear in all the official american
pie sequels and even anchor three
direct-to-video raunchy comedies under
the american pie presents banner levy
co-starred opposite steve martin in
bringing down the house and alongside
samuel jackson in the men and he was a
pivotal part of christopher guest's
troupe of improv adept comic actors in
the mockumentary's best in show a mighty
wind and for your consideration but
levy's most recent success overshadows
everything else even american pie with
his son dan levy he created the riches
to rags canadian sitcom shit's creek he
starred as johnny rose a role that won
him an emmy award when shit's creek
swept the comedy portion of the ceremony
in 2020.
aside from the original harold and kumar
trailer there aren't many reminders that
john cho was in american pie new line
cinema presents that asian guy from
american pie but whether you realize it
or not he's one of the reasons you know
what a milf is
m-i-l-f
mom i'd like to
yeah
john cho was indeed one of the so-called
milf guys in american pie though he also
popped up in a couple of vocal jazz
group scenes while cho would go on to a
bigger role and actually be credited as
jon in subsequent american pie sequels
his milf chanting moment in the original
flick is likely the first time most
moviegoers took note of the actor his
career has shifted dramatically in the
years since with cho scoring a co-lead
opposite kal pen in the stoner cult
classic harald and kumar franchise he's
also featured prominently in the recent
star trek movies and landed charming
one-off turns in tv hits like new girl
and how i met your mother most recently
however cho has made a name for himself
on the indie scene via lauded films like
columbus gemini and searching he also
played the iconic spike spiegel in the
short-lived live-action reboot of the
anime classic cowboy bebop when she
appeared as an object of lust and desire
aka stifler's mom in american pie
jennifer coolidge wasn't well known
outside of comedy circles she'd appeared
on the short-lived mid 90s network
sketch comedy show she tv and had popped
up in seinfeld and at night at the rock
spree
what's up not much just giving you an 80
ticket
she is so into you but american pie
along with christopher guest's 2000
semi-improvised mockumentary best in
show would provide coolidge back-to-back
career breaks showcasing her skill at
playing kooks weirdos and ditzes you
most likely remember her role as the
friendly manicurist and confidante
paulette in both popular legally blonde
movies she eventually re-teamed with
guests for a mighty wind and four-year
consideration while also reprising her
role as stifler's mom in the american
pie sequels she portrayed joey's agent
on the friend spin-off joey joined the
cast of two broke girls and earned rave
reviews for her more dramatic work on
the hbo vacation from hell miniseries
the white lotus
you